Hi everyone. Good afternoon. My name
is Katie Gray and I work at the uh,
presentation design from Duarte were where
these ladies lead and I actually used
to work at Google so it's exciting to be
back here and I'm honored to introduce
them. Um, so Nancy Duarte,
she's a CEO of Duarte.
It's a firm that's created over a quarter
of a million presentations over the
past 28 years in Silicon Valley.
And Nancy has written five best selling
books about using visual storytelling in
business communications,
including resonate and slide ology.
And the latest book aluminate,
which she'll be talking about today.
Her work has been featured in fortune
wire, the Wall Street Journal,
New York Times, many, many other places.
And then Patti Sanchez is the
chief strategy officer of Duarte.
She has over 25 years of
experience leading transformative
marketing initiatives
for global brands like Adobe,
Cisco, Ericsson, Nike, Vm ware, Ge,
and many more.
And her lifelong passion is helping
communicators engage empathetically and
authentically. So Nancy and
Patty are going to speak to
you about their new book,
illuminate, ignite change
through speeches, stories,
ceremonies, and symbols.
If any of you have tried to convince
a group of people to go on a long,
arduous journey somewhere,
even though you knew it was worth it,
but you had to convince them,
then this book is for you. Uh,
the book is a result of
years of research into many,
many business case studies from the
likes of Steve Jobs or Mary Barra or Lou
Gerstner, uh, at IBM. And
it's very informative. Um, I
think were very much enjoy it.
And today you're going to hear about
some key principles in that book to help
you lead people to a vision.
So with that,
I'd like to welcome Nancy
Duarte and Patti Sanchez.
Thanks Katie.
Katie Gray.
I love working with her and
I also love talking, right?
So she might know, I love talking
about storytelling. As Katie said,
we're big fans of visual
storytelling at Duarte.
And I assume that you're all fans of it
to some degree, which is why you're here.
And a lot of people recognize the power
of storytelling as a communication tool,
especially for marketers.
A lot of brands use storytelling to
create affection for their products and to
get people to fall in love with their
companies and the things that they offer.
But what a lot of people maybe don't
realize is that storytelling is actually a
leadership tool.
And so we're going to talk to you today
about how leaders and people like you
can use storytelling to inspire
others to do big things.
And really we think that the job of
a leader is to create the future.
So what does that really
mean? Well, first of all,
I think it's the difference between a
manager and a leader is that a manager is
somebody who maintains what is,
they just keep the current thing going.
A leader is somebody who
creates what could be,
they make something new possible that
didn't exist before and it's not an easy
thing to do to create something new.
And you may not even think
of yourself as a leader,
but if you're doing anything
that makes a new future possible,
then you are a leader.
Your,
your taking people into a territory
that they've never been in before,
which can be creating a new feature
in launching it to the world.
It can be building a process of some kind.
It can be a hiring or training people.
All of those things create a capability
that didn't exist before to make
something new.
The challenges that,
that new future you're trying to bring
into being actually represents change
because you're envisioning
something that didn't yet exist.
You're going to have to get other people
to agree that this new thing is a good
idea and to get them to
help you make it a reality.
And that's not easy because most
people don't like change. Uh, you know,
some of you might actually be
kind of comfortable with change,
especially if you have an entrepreneurial
kind of spirit. So then maybe the,
the white space excites you that the
average human being is frightened by that.
They're frightened by the unknown
because it requires them to do things,
to learn things that they don't
understand and that stretchy.
And so whenever you introduce a new idea,
you're effectively asking people to do
something differently than what they've
done before. And most people are
going to resist that in some way.
And it may not even look like
outright a revolt to you.
It might just sound like doubt.
They might say,
how do we know that the best idea or
how do we know it's better than the way
things happen right now?
Or maybe the way we used to do things
was the right way to do things.
And all of those are signs that
they're going to resist this change.
And so if you have an idea and you want
to motivate people to help you make that
idea reality,
you actually have to have a plan for
how you're going to lead them on what we
call a venture of venture into the future.
So venture is an interesting
word because it has two meanings,
especially in Silicon Valley.
A lot of people think of a venture is
sort of like a startup. You know, you're,
it's a noun that means it's a new thing.
But adventure is also a verb.
It's actually the act of going somewhere.
And it's also sort of like metaphorically
and adventure and expedition into a
territory that people
haven't been in before.
So if you think about traveling to
a place you've never been to before,
what is helpful?
It's often helpful to have a map some
way to visually understand where you are
and where you need to go and what
the path might be between them.
So what is a map of a venture into the
future potentially look like what we
think there's a common symbol in business
that actually describes what this
journey looks like and it's
the s curve of innovation.
And what it does is it describes the
life cycle of a business or have an idea
from its beginning to its end from it
start to its growth to its maturity.
And the challenge is that when that idea
or the organization that's created that
reaches maturity,
then stagnation sets in.
Because as I said,
people don't like change.
So they're going to kind of
like dig in their heels and say,
let's just enjoy the way things are.
Like now that we've got it working,
let's just ride us.
But if you don't evolve,
if that idea doesn't
continue to grow and evolve,
then that stagnation can lead to decline
or even death, this downward slide.
So it's the job of a leader to imagine
another future and lead another venture
to go there and to do it
again and to do it again.
Because for organizations
and even people to thrive,
they have to constantly
reinvent themselves.
So what leaders have to do is figure
out how to bring people along with them.
And we've worked with all kinds of leaders
in our years of consulting at Duarte
and, and, and before that.
And we've studied what the
greatest leaders do to bring
people along with them.
And we found that they're
all great communicators,
but they also use specific kinds of
communication tools to bring people along
with them. So we're going to
talk a little bit about those.
This is what we consider the toolkit
that great leaders use to bring people
along with them on that venture into the
future. The first is telling stories.
They also deliver speeches
and they hold ceremonies.
So stories are a great communication
tool because they engage people,
they make us feel something.
If you watch a really interesting movie,
you know that you get caught up in it and
you have all the fields, you know the,
the joy and the pain and the fear.
And the same is true of stories
that we tell in our lives.
And that leaders can tell is a way to
create an emotional connection with the
people that they're talking to.
So they cause us to feel something.
And actually when I'm telling you a story,
uh,
my brainwaves actually start to align
with yours or yours align with mine
because I'm feeling we're feeling the
same thing together at the same time.
And that same connection happens between
the people who are all hearing the
story together.
So it's actually a way to unite groups
of people around a common experience.
Now, another reason why stories are
really powerful tool for leading people is
because stories are about change
fundamentally at their heart.
Any story is about a person who has to
go through a journey of some kind and
ultimately is transformed by it.
And that's really what a
definition of a story is.
And there's a lot of confusion out there.
A lot of people talking about story and
saying that they're storytellers, uh,
when we don't think they're necessarily
true stories that they're communicating.
So this is the definition
in its purest form of story.
It goes all the way back to Aristotle
and he said, a story has three parts.
It has a beginning,
a middle and enhance.
In the beginning we meet the likable hero.
This is the protagonist.
This is the person who's
just trying to do life.
And then something happens and
inciting incident, they call it, uh,
that the rows, that hero's world
off balance and usually, uh,
actually causes them to leave that place,
that home and go somewhere new.
And in the process of traveling from
what they know to this new territory,
they encounter all kinds of roadblocks.
In the middle of that story
because it's all new territory.
They might have to fight monsters or
aliens and they even are challenged to
their inner core and often end up
questioning who they are and what they're
capable of,
but ultimately at the end of the story,
through grit and determination,
the overcome those obstacles and they
come out the other side different
transformed.
So that's why stories are actually a
really powerful way to help people cope
with change because they described
the process of change itself.
Now there's another tool that
leaders use. Whoops. Before that,
this is actually the shape of a story
and what you can see here is that the
middle of the story is where all the
action happens. Literally action.
The rising action increases tension and
the falling action releases that tension
and it's that increase of tension and
the release of tension that keeps us
engaged in the story. It
creates contrast. Now,
as I was about to say, there's another
tool that leaders use to communicate,
and you probably recognize this.
You may do it yourself and not
realize that you're giving a speech.
But speeches are not just the big talks,
like the vision thing.
You know when when the leader stands up
in front of the organization and says,
this is where we're going this year,
uh, speech is also a progress update.
You know, here's where we
are in our project, here's
what we're going to do next.
A speech is also an announcement
about good news or bad news.
All of those are
opportunities not to just,
not just to inform people about
what's happening and what's next,
but also to inspire them and engage them.
Now we've studied also storytelling
principles and how they can be applied to
speeches.
And a few years ago,
Nancy made an incredible discovery that
there's a pattern to those speeches that
the greatest communicators give and so
she can do a better job of explaining it.
So I'm going to send her up.
So after spending about four
years studying storytelling,
I was wondering why some speeches
have this cadence and a rhythm to it.
It's like it builds tension and released
it and it would build tension and
release.
It was just you were drawn in.
So after doing a journey through story
and then going through the hundred top
best speeches of all time,
I actually found what that pattern is and
it is based in the tension and release
of storytelling. And so I want to
show you the shape that I discovered.
This is a structural shape over time.
I mean it has a beginning,
a middle and an end.
And that pulsing in the cadence is the
building of tension and releasing it from
storytelling.
Now this has a three act structure
just like a great story does.
So the beginning of any,
I'm going to say presentations,
but this works for any type of
communication work from email.
This could work for a blog post
and helps me get my husband to do
tours on the weekend. Like it
works. It persuades. Um, so, uh,
the beginning is you need to establish
what is and what you're doing is you're
basically, you're basically
saying, what's our shared truth?
This is what we all believe as true.
This is the state of the union.
This is the budget,
this is where we're at financially.
That's kind of what you do. And then
what happens is you insert what could be,
and this is like the
inciting incident in a story.
Suddenly your world is out of balance.
And that gap between what is and
what could be winds up being,
what gets resolved through
the rest of your talk.
The middle moves back and
forth structurally between
what is, what could be,
what is and what could be.
So the human brain is wired for contrast
and we can actually see the gap.
The audience can see, oh,
if that's what currently is,
but this is what could be
suddenly what is isn't.
It is an interesting and what
could be is more appealing.
So that's how it works
as a structural tool. Um,
the last vertical line is the call to
action and every talk should have won,
but you shouldn't end there.
You should end with the new bliss.
This is you describing this future state
that's going to be amazing if everyone
adopts your idea. It's the
new bliss, the new norm.
So once I had this shape,
I've analyzed so many talks.
I want to just show you
some, I have, um, uh,
I've done a ted talk
that goes into detail,
but I just want to show
you some quickly, um, um,
because we've analyzed a ton of them.
So we have a Margaret Thatcher
in her iron lady speech.
You can see she starts off with
what is, she's pretty rapid. Um,
when she talked to parliament, it was
a kind of this one, one punch to punch.
Like what is, what could be, what
is what could be all the time.
So you can see she starts off with what
is and moves back and forth between what
is and what could be ending high end to
the right, stating the new bliss. Um,
Richard Fineman, very famous
caltech professor, um,
he was a physics professor and kids
would like run across campus to see his
class, even if they didn't need to take
it. He was known as the great explainer.
He did a law of gravity speech and
you could see it's a technical speech,
yet it moves really rapidly between
what is and what could be Steve Jobs,
iPhone launch speech. He has a
heightened sense of what could be, um,
in all of his speeches.
But it does move back and forth between
what is and what could be. And of course,
Dr King's very famous.
I have a dream speech also starts off
with what is moves back and forth.
And you can see the frequency. You get
really tight, about two thirds in, um,
that was his very famous,
I have a dream sequence.
I have a dream that one day
I have a dream that one day.
What's interesting is some of the
most beloved parts of our most beloved
speeches are the gap between what is
and what could be at the phrase level as
they move back and forth between.
I have a dream that one day he did not
call this the, I have a dream speech.
He actually called it the fierce urgency
of now that was the actual official
title.
The people named at the,
I have a dream speech because of this
very beloved. I'm sequence right here.
So those are pretty lofty people and
you're like, but I just work at Google.
I just had this thing I need to do. I'm
not driving the civil rights movements.
I'll bring it closer to home.
Using an example of a female,
and it's my 11 year old niece,
she wrote a letter to a dad because she
wanted a mouse now and then an 11 year
old mind. This is the most important
thing in her life right now.
So she writes an impassioned plea that
follows the form perfectly. She says,
Dear Dad, we want a mouse. And you might
say they're stinky, but they're not.
If you put special drops in their water,
you might say that they're mean,
but you rarely find an aggressive mouse.
If they do bite,
it's usually just a curiosity. Nebel I
know you will not want to pay for it.
Sophie and I have that covered.
We've saved our birthday money so we can
pay for the mouse and everything else
and you will not have
to pay a single cent.
Also the mouse will be
in Sophie's or my rooms.
You will not have to see it all the time.
And the new bliss is we will
respect any decision you make.
They got the mouse.
So you can see what's interesting to me
is it's almost like we are hardwired.
She's not seeing my book's
come to my workshop.
I did not design this letter for her.
She wanted it so bad.
She used a persuasive story pattern
with the tension and release of story.
So it's amazing when you really need to
give an impassioned plea how important
that is.
So one of the third story based
concepts that we're introducing into the
business vernacular is the idea
of ceremonies and ceremonies.
Some of the oldest artifacts we can find
are actually artifacts that were used
in ritual because of a,
a group of people felt they needed
communal catharsis around their community.
And so it's also based in the same
three x structure. That story is.
But the naming conventions are different.
We looked at the rights of passage
because that is the most common in society
today. A marriage, a
graduation, a bar Mitzvah. Um,
but because we were both
married to Hispanic men,
we're going to use the Keaton Yada
as an example. And what that is is,
is when a young girl turns 15,
she goes through a rights of passage,
similar to a bar Mitzvah,
but she comes in a little flat shoes
and a drabby little dress and she's
carrying a Dolly.
So what she's doing is she's actually
going to be separating from that version
of her identity. She goes through
a ceremony and she transitions.
The minute the ceremony is done,
suddenly she's a woman. Okay?
So she gets rid of her doll, she gets to
wear high heels, puts on a little Tiara,
and she's a woman. Now, all that
happened was three minutes of time.
She went from being a little girl and
suddenly she's a woman just because of the
ceremony of ceremonies. What they do
is they mark endings and beginnings.
This is over.
I'm not a little girl.
I've let go of my girlish
things and I am a woman now,
we'll corporations need to practice
the concept of endings and beginnings
because when you're trying to transform
a collective consciousness of people,
there are things that end and
there are things that begin again,
it's very important to understand endings
and beginnings and the power that they
hold. If people can let go of the old,
they're more willing to embrace the new.
And we have a case study
in a minute about that.
So this is the basic toolkit
that communicators need
as you're driving your own
teams. And I'll bring a patty
back up here again to talk about
how to do that. Yeah, she
has, I lose my shoe. Well,
that toolkit that Nancy,
uh,
recap just there is what we
call a torch bearers toolkit.
And the reason we use the word torchbearer
is because it's the job of a leader
to eliminate the path between the
present and the future. You know, again,
when you think about this metaphorically
as an expedition to a place people have
never been to before, into the
unknown, uh, metaphorically,
that unknown is sort of a dark and scary
place to people. Or at least it's foggy.
It's hard for them to visualize it and
to understand it and feel safe going
there.
So through effective communication leaders
of basically like that path so that
people can see where they need
to go and how to get there.
And if leaders communicate really well,
they create moments that move people,
moments that make people feel bigger
and more capable than they realize that
they were the create the capacity for
people to do things that they didn't
realize they could do.
But the bigger your idea is,
the more change you're
going to ask people to make.
And the more change
you ask people to make,
the more you're going to have to
persuade them to actually go there.
Which means you're going to have to
communicate over and over and over because
transformational change
doesn't happen overnight,
but it's going to take
is actually a movement.
And what is a movement anyway?
You know, what movement is, is uh,
a massive group of people
going somewhere together,
usually over a long period of time.
It can be weeks,
but often it's months or
years or even decades.
And we've had many leaders say to us,
they wanted to create
movements around their ideas.
And that launched us on this quest to
understand how movements actually happened
and what they really look like.
And so as we mapped the
forms that communication can
take the shape of a story,
the shape of a speech, we wondered is
there actually a shape to a movement too?
And we studied business
movements like an open source.
We studied social movements like civil
rights and we looked at all the things
that leaders did,
all the communication that they gave and,
and how that unfolded over time.
And we discovered that they do actually
follow a shape which is magically the s
curve of innovation,
which is basically mapping the path
between what is the present state and what
could be,
which is the future.
But we also discovered that those
movements follow a story structure too.
Just like the communication
that you use to move people,
and so this is that story structure of a
movement which we call a venture escape.
It's that landscape of the venture
into the, so it has three acts,
just like a story with five stages in the
first act or the dream and leap stages,
dream happens when you the leader,
whoever's the advocate for an
idea declares the vision. You say,
this is what I see, this is where
I want us to go. Let's go there.
But immediately as soon as
you communicate that vision,
people are faced with a choice about
whether they're going to say, yes, I'm in,
or whether they're going to say no,
I'm out.
So they have a choice to commit or resist.
And how well you communicate directly
affects how likely they are to say yes.
And when they do say yes,
when they leap into this venture with you,
then the middle of the story
starts to unfold in the middle.
Just like in a great story that you might
see in a movie is where all the action
happens and translated in real life.
That means where all the
hard stuff happens because
in the middle are the fight
and climb stages.
The fight is when you're,
anybody is trying to bring
that idea to reality.
The status quo rises up against it.
Anybody who's defending the way things
are and the fact that they should stay
the same is going to put up resistance.
And so people have to
overcome those obstacles.
They have to fight that
internal inertia or the external
criticism of this idea. But every time
that you overcome one of those obstacles,
they gain a little more ground.
They climb a little closer,
get a little closer to that end goal.
And the middle is really the hard part.
It's where people are tested.
Just like in a story that hero comes to
question whether they have the stuff to
continue and how well you communicate
will determine whether they think they can
finish. And that's when the third
act of the story comes to an end,
which is the arrived stage.
The arrived stage is where you achieve
your goal or at least you conclude that
effort and it could be a happy
ending like in the movies,
but most likely it won't
be perfectly happy.
You might fall short of
your goal a little bit.
You might not achieve what you thought
you would, it might change shape,
but at that point in the journey,
it's important to look back to say,
what did we actually accomplish?
Where did we fall short and how do we
avoid those mistakes in the future?
Also, you have to communicate frequently
throughout this process and your
communication has to take on a different
flavor depending on the stage of the
journey that you're in because people
have different emotional needs at each
stage. In the beginning of the
journey, that first stage in dream,
what they need is a moment of inspiration.
They need to believe in that idea.
They need to be able to imagine themselves
in that future and long to go there.
In the leap stage, what they really
need is a moment of decision.
They need help choosing whether
to say yes or whether to say no,
and hopefully they'll say yes.
The fight stage is a moment of bravery.
That's when people need to be reminded
that they're capable of overcoming those
obstacles.
To feel courageous,
willing to risk anything to fight
to make your idea a reality.
The climb stage,
which is kind of a misnomer because it
can be a very long drawn out process of
getting closer to the goal. And what
people really need then is endurance.
They need to be reminded that they have
reserves deep inside of themselves that
they can call upon so that
they can overcome, keep
going, and ultimately finish.
And in the end, what people
need is a moment of reflection.
This is a time to stop,
to catch your breath before you
rush off to the next initiative, to,
to tell the stories of
what you just went through,
to celebrate them or to more the endings
before they start the next journey.
So I want to tell you about one leader
that I think did this really well in his
name, may not be familiar to
you. Um, but it's, it's, uh,
I have a lot of affection for him.
His name is Ray Anderson,
and he was the CEO and founder of a
company called interface interface was
founded in the 1970s when ray had this
idea that it was kind of crazy at the
time to create carpet tiles,
basically take big rolls of carpet and
cut them up into squares because he
thought it was a good idea.
And so he convinced a few investors to
give him some money and he started this
business and it turned out to be the
right idea at the right time because the
office environments we're changing.
And so this modular carpeting
was a really good concept.
And so he grew that business
like gangbusters for 20 years.
It became the world's largest supplier
of carpet tiles and he was making money
hand over fist,
a self made millionaire.
And everything was great until the 1990s
when everybody started to wake up to
the climate problem,
the environmental problems that the,
that we were all experiencing.
And they were starting to, uh,
criticize industrial businesses who
they believed were causing the problems.
And so customers even started asking, Ray,
what are you doing for the environment?
And he was really troubled by the question
because he couldn't answer it is only
answer was, I'm just trying to stay out
of jail, which is not a good strategy.
So coincidentally an employee
sent them a copy of this book,
the Ecology of Commerce by Paul Hawkin,
one of the founders of Smith and Hawken.
And so ray devoured this book looking
for an answer to that question.
And what he saw was this,
you said he convicted me as
a plunderer of the earth,
which is a horrible thing to hear,
especially for a founder. He said,
I built this company that
is plundering the earth.
And he said it hit him
like a spear in the chest.
He would tell people that story over
and over about the epiphany that he had.
And he was compelled to come up
with a new dream for his company.
And this is how he articulated it.
He said,
what if interface became the first
industrial company in the world to achieve
sustainability?
And he used to story metaphorical journey
of climbing a mountain taller than
Everest to describe this vision. And he
always drew this picture to depict it.
And he would use that over and over in
his communications to help people really
understand and imagine
themselves achieving that goal.
He knew it was going to take a
lot of work to make that happen.
So he called all of his leaders
together for an offsite in Maui, Hawaii,
and he asked Paul Hawkin to
actually give the keynote.
So Paul Hawkin stood up and he talked
about all the problems that were affecting
the planet,
but also all the things that individuals
can do this global village to turn
things around and make a difference.
And then ray got up and spoke and he
asked every single one of his leaders to
make a personal commitment
to do something different,
to put the environment back in balance.
But he didn't just ask them,
he asks them to demonstrate
that commitment in front
of everybody right then and
there. So they all wrote pledges on cards
that they pinned up next to photos of
themselves on what they called a
personal legacy wall. It was a ceremony,
a pledging commitment to change.
And after that ceremony,
the leaders were galvanized.
They raced forward and they kicked off
all kinds of initiatives across the
company to do things differently to
transform the way they did business.
And over the next 20 years
they really changed everything,
top to bottom in the company,
everything about how they operated and
they also transformed their industry.
So why do I tell you this story about
Ray Anderson? A couple of reasons. One,
because he's an entrepreneur, somebody
who made something out of nothing.
And I think that's really inspiring too
because he put his entire business and
service of a purpose greater than profit,
which I also also think is
really inspiring. But three,
because he was a leader who understood
the power of communication and
storytelling and used it to motivate
people to do really big things.
He's not the only one.
There are a lot of leaders who did this
really well and so Nancy is going to
tell you about one more.
So I want to do a quick cut.
Hey, I'm about apple. As
you guys know, I'm Steve.
Jobs was kicked out of his own company,
went away for 10 years and
built a different company
with a different operating
system, but in the time that Mr jobs was
gone from apple, apple had no strategy.
They tried a few times to create
an operating system and failed,
so they had to go outside of apple,
look to buy an operating system they
bought next and with next came Mr. Jobs,
the very first time Mr job spoke,
even though it was a broad audience,
it was not at a developers conference.
If there were news was there,
it was a Mac world.
He spoke as if it was only talking
to the developers in the room.
He had 20 minutes in.
He used the word developer 27 times
because he knew the developers had to move
from Mac os nine to Mac os 10 or the whole
company would fail. It was huge. Nope.
Gilamelio spoke for three hours and he
said the word developer three times.
No wonder he wasn't the right guy to lead.
Did you gotta realize apple wasn't
a complete crisis at this time? Um,
the developers were very,
very skeptical cause they had
been jerked around for a decade.
They do a build in the next year
they find out everything was wasted.
They do another build and it was
wasted. So very skeptical. In fact,
Mr Jobs did a talk actually called
Apple's hierarchy of skepticism.
We went through all the
steps of skepticism and where
the developers were in the
spectrum because they were that skeptical.
So what happened is 2001 a lot of
the developers still were not moving.
They were still not migrating
and he did a ceremony.
He stood up and he made a vow.
He unfurled and oversized
piece of parchment paper and
he made a verbal vow that
I will stick with one
operating system strategy.
Some of the developers hadn't
moved because they thought
that they were going to
keep jerking them around.
What happened that was kind of
interesting is in the middle of the climb,
a lot of times at the s curves overlap.
That's the time you need to
already be dreaming again.
So the developers are still moving.
A lot of them had come,
but some pretty big ones had decided
to resist and decided not to come.
In the meantime, Mr Jobs had a new dream
he was already on, but the real dream,
he'd had this New Vision that the whole
world of connected devices would connect
to Mac os 10 it was called
this digital hub strategy.
If you go and you look at this speech,
he'd basically prophesied their entire
hardware strategy for the next decade.
It was a big speech, so it was a dream.
So of course he's losing his patients.
He's like,
get on to 10 get on to 10
but he keeps telling me,
get on to 10 I've got this new dream.
Oh my God,
you're not gonna believe what the world
is going to look like. So he decides,
you know what,
we need to bury the old OSTP.
We need to bury macro s nine
and he did exactly that.
He actually had a coffin and
smoke come up out of the stage,
stained glass up on the wall.
Erie music played.
He came out with an oversized a Macalester
nine you can see there to the right,
put it in the coffin, closed
the lid, put a red bows on it,
and he said a eulogy from [inaudible].
He said,
we are here today to mourn the passing
of macro s nine he is now in that great
big luck it in the sky.
No doubt looking down upon us with that
same smile he displayed every time he
booted.
Mr Jobs never mentioned Mac os nine again.
After this day it was done in the
developers that they're there.
Like you could actually hear it
in the audio. They're like, Whoa,
like your response to laugh or when
they'll never forget it was over.
It was done. So this is a ceremony
of endings and beginnings. Move on.
He said language like the
train has left the station.
People are going to buy another brand.
Then your brand. He pushed them out.
Endings and beginnings. He pushed them
forward. Some got pushed out maybe,
but it is fun to be a leader myself.
Some of you might be like, well,
I'm not really a leader,
but I've had the privilege of being able
to kind of prophetically imagine my own
organization's future and then had kind
of the power and the autonomy to move it
into this new alternate future and one
things consistent is change itself.
I'm sure you've heard that,
but my own organization is 28 years old.
We are on our eighth reinvention.
That means we've reinvented
ourselves every four years,
which I think is fascinating because
the u s board of Labor and Statistics
states that small businesses
die between four and five years,
so it's almost like the life cycle of
just my own little unit of 120 people
actually needs to be rejuvenated
in about four year increments.
Now Google does that at a scale that
this isn't even messy enough to show you
guys have hundreds of venture scapes,
hundreds of them going on all the time,
which means every single one of you in
this room are either leading a venture
scape or you being impacted by someone
else that's leading a venture scape.
That means that there's a lot of other
travelers that need to come along with
you.
You have other people.
These ideas are not going to be realized
if you can't get others to come along
with you and make that dream a reality.
It's why learning to communicate well
is so critical and you're gonna have
moments all the time, all along the
way where there's a speech of story,
of ceremony, Bam, Bam, Bam. Every day a
speech, oh, I need to tell a story too.
I need to do a ceremony today.
You may have a one on one with one of
your direct reports who's encountered a
roadblock and you're like, oh,
I remember in when I did this.
Here's the story of how I overcame
that same roadblock. A speech.
You've got the vision meetings,
you've got the all hands meetings,
you've got your staff meeting speeches
all the time. And then there's ceremonies.
Oh my gosh,
we just launched this initiative.
Let's all sign the great poster that
was just made and make a commitment that
we're going to make this reality.
Those happen all day long.
But there's these other moments that
happen when the team may be missed it.
The team needs to heal.
The team needs to be galvanized,
they need to be rallied.
It's a bigger moment along all those
other moments where you need to create
collective effervescence,
this moment where the people are bound
to each other and bound to you and
recommitted to what you're asking them to
do. And those stand out among the rest.
And that's when you need to combine
the stories, the ceremonies,
and the speeches into a moment that
people will never forget because this is
when they actually recommit.
They're so exhausted, so beat up.
Sometimes they need a moment to decide,
is this worth it?
Can I keep going and do I
want to keep doing that?
So moving people is really hard.
Um,
just because maybe I have this skill
for seeing the future doesn't mean I've
always been really good at getting
people to go there. In fact,
I used to just at the vision
meeting every year at my company,
I would just make this epic declaration
of what needed to happen and then I
would check in with myself at the end of
the year and be disappointed sometimes,
mostly in my travelers if they didn't
make my dream come true that I told them
once,
you know,
and it's so weird to see how
hard it is to move people,
but I had to finally own, like I
thought it was like, well, why?
Why don't they want to do this?
Why are we not working together to make
this happen? And I had to realize, well,
maybe it's partly that
the sacrifice is huge.
I'm asking him to do.
I had not honored the fact that
maybe they had to spend more time,
they had to learn new skills,
the sacrifice they were going to have
to make to make this dream come true,
but also was I portraying it in a way
that made the risks seem worth the reward
to them?
Was the risk worth the reward?
Did I really think for a minute that
they're encountering these obstacles that
might be just too hard for
them and moving them is really,
really hard and it's empathy that
unlocks something inside of them.
So I don't, I don't and haven't
had that much empathy in my career.
I had to learn it. And if you look at
these two models we showed you today,
they're actually models for empathy so
the leader can actually think through and
see things from someone
else's perspective.
And I was actually raised by a narcissist
and a narcissist doesn't have the
empathy gene.
It's actually a mental illness where
the empathy gene is just vacant.
That means I didn't have
empathy modeled for me as a kid.
My mom never showed me what that means
to think and consider someone else's
perspective.
So my body of work is actually my own
personal journey at calling this thing
called empathy that was evasive to me.
It was gone and I couldn't
really grasp it or find it.
So I had to create models so I could see
things from other people's perspective.
And I have to confess,
I have opened my own book that I wrote
myself with Patty and I've had to look at
the model to do a couple of talks in my
own shop so that it works to consider
how somebody else may be perceiving
what you're asking them to do and then
communicate through that and
from that place. And you know,
what does storytelling that binds us
together. Everything you learned today,
all the models are based in storytelling.
And I can tell you that if you adopt
the concepts and principles of story,
your career will never be the same.
It is the very thing that will move you
from simply a manager to being a leader
is how you choose to communicate the
actions you're wanting others to take. On.
That's the sole difference. Like
Tati was saying, it's, it's a tool.
It's hardwired into our brains
to bind the teller to the heroes,
to the listener.
It binds us to each other.
Storytelling also connects
you with each other.
When you've experienced an amazing story,
you feel connected to each other and it
really changes the trajectory of where
you're going and how
quickly you can get there.
So if you think about the concept
of story being about transforming,
it creates longing. If people are
trying to change and get somewhere,
the journey's hard and its story,
that's the coping mechanism.
It's story that helps them recommit it's
story that makes them want to continue
to build the future you're
portraying that needs to be built.
Stories create a longing.
I'm like anything else in,
in any sort of communication.
So I want to end with a quote and then
we'll take questions from you guys.
If you want to build a ship,
don't drum up people together to collect
wood and don't assign them tasks and
work, but rather teach them to long
for the endless immensity of the sea.
If Google in principle and conceptually
would embrace the power of storytelling,
you guys are already great
and unstoppable. Yeah.
I can't even imagine what could be calm
because you guys actually do change the
entire world.
And so we would love to take questions.
We also have a gift as you leave today.
We brought the actual insert from
the book, the communication tool kit,
which has, um, speeches,
stories and ceremonies, and
it has the dream leap, fight,
climb. I love arrive. We have warnings,
speeches, and motivating speeches,
warning stories, motivating
stories, morning ceremonies, Morgan,
easterners with this out.
Use it as your map and
change the world like crazy.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.